[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle année dans Parlement
Hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité au Parlement
et pour cette première de l'année nous
accueillons Erwan balanan bonjour vous
êtes député MoDem du finisterè merci
d'être avec nous pour commenter cette
semaine de reprise au Parlement et on
parlera du baptême du feu pour Gabriel
Atal cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale première question d'actualité
pour le nouveau Premier ministre à la
tête d'un gouvernement marqué à droite
et puis on reviendra sur les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron mardi soir lors de sa
conférence de presse le président de la
République a annoncé une batterie de
mesures pour réussir je cite le
réarmement civique de la France ce qui
n'a pas convaincu les oppositions et
puis l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale le ministre de la
Justice éric dupontmetti a été
auditionné sur le projet de loi qui vise
à inscrire dans la Constitution la
liberté des femmes de courir à l'IVG
Emmanuel Macron espère une adoption du
texte par le Parlement en mars prochain
les parlementaires seront alors réunis
en congrès à
versaill c'était donc la première séance
de question au gouvernement pour Gabriel
hatal nouveau Premier ministre pas de
coup d'clat particulier ni de clash mais
plusieurs moments forts lors de ces QAG
que l'on va revoir avec Stéphanie
despierr à l'Assemblée pour le plus
jeune premier ministre de la 5e
République tout commence par une
à 34 ans devant les députés de son camp
Gabriel Atal vient d'endosser le costume
de chef de la majorité présidentielle 4
He plus tard première séance de question
gouvernement il cherche à imposer sa
marque oui des Français traverse de très
grandes difficultés oui il y a des
Français qui doutent il y a des Français
qui souffrent il y a des Français en
colère des Français qui n'y croient plus
et je le dis je ne tomberai jamais dans
le fatalisme consistant a pens que les
problèmes des Français ne peuvent pas
être réglés dans l'attente d'une
nouvelle vague de nomination les bands
des ministres sont en partie vide son
gouvernement n'est pas encore complet
Gabriel hatal est déjà la cible de la
gauche ceci n'est pas un remanimement
c'est un
effondrement artisan du malheur des
Français depuis bientôt 7 ans puis
Premier ministre depuis 7 jours d'un
gouvernement que vous n'avez pas choisi
vous étiez minoritaire en 2023 vous
serez minoritaire en 2024 regarde pas
d'où les gens viennent je regarde où ils
veulent aller je ne regarde pas les gens
pour ceux qu'ils sont mais pour ce
qu'ils font vous vous présentez devant
nous avec un gouvernement qui fait
figure d'aveux fin du en même temps et
cohabitation assumée avec la droite dure
après la préférence nationale voici la
préférence Sarkozi j'assume totalement
s'il vous plaît je préfère travailler
avec rachidti Catherine vaterin comme
moi qu'avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon comme
vous voilà jeudi Gabriel a réuni ses
ministres pour préparer son discours de
politique générale il a décidé de
prendre son temps ce sera le 30 janvier
soit 3 semaines après sa nomination mais
le nouveau locataire de Matignon ne veut
prendre aucun risque il ne se soumettra
pas au vote de confiance de l'Assemblée
nationale eran banan vous avez observé
les premiers cas les premiers pas de
Gabriel hatal comme premier ministre
est-ce que ça fait du bien d'avoir un
profil
politique madame borne était aussi
politique mais dans un autre style euh
c'est sûr que Gabriel Atal a une
facilité à c'est un tribin en réalité
c'est c'est un tribin moderne jeune avec
une aisance dans dans dans le dans le
combat politique et dans le l'ajoute
politique et je pense oui que ça ça peut
être un vrai atout parce qu'on on a
besoin en réalité de d'expliquer un
certain nombre de choses et surtout
expliquer les bonnes choses qu'on a
faites depuis 6 ans moi je suis frappé
par tout un tas de mesures qui ont été
qui nous qui ont préservé les Français
durant cette période de covid durant
cette période de de boucliers
tarifairire toutes les réformes que nous
avons mis en place qui ont permis à la
France de de d'avoir un taux de chômage
historiquement bas tout ça il faut qu'on
le rappelle et c'est vrai que Gabriel
Atal a cette pugnacité à cette
combativité qui sans doute nous fera du
bien et pourtant sa nomination ne va pas
changer la donne à l'Assemblée nationale
car Gabriel Atal n'aura toujours pas de
majorité absolue dans l'hémicycle non ça
changera pas la don la donne d'un point
de vue on va dire numéraire d'un point
de vue de de des équilibres des forces
maintenant Gabriel Atal a l'immense
avantage d'avoir été un parlementaire
qui qui ass siégé Elisabeth borne était
parlementaire mais elle n'avait pas elle
n'avait pas eu la grande chance de de
siéger à l'Assemblée donc il connaît les
rouages il connaî comment on peut
négocier et et surtout comment on peut
emporter certaines majorité mais je
rappelle quand même il faut rappeler au
français que sur la séquence qui vient
de se passer des 18 mois de depuis
l'élection on a passé plus de 50 textes
21 textes à l'unanimité donc c'est
parfaitement possible d'avoir des des
des majorités de projets c'était un des
c'était une des ambitions de de de
Madame borne et en réalité elle a réussi
on retient que les 493 mais les 493
c'est juste quatre textes budgétaires et
un texte budgéaire assez particulierers
qui étaient les retraites les autres
textes sont tous passés 1493 alors
revenons sur la composition politique du
gouvernement puisque Gabriel hatal a
nommé un gouvernement plutôt marqué à
droite Rachid Dati Catherine Vautrin
sans oubli Bruno Lemire et Damana votre
collègue du MoDem Jean-Louis bourlange
aurait préféré dit-il que le modem
soutienne ce gouvernement dominé par
d'ancien sarkoziste mais sans y
participer est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui pas enfin enfin c'était une
option mais la la réalité on a
effectivement deux personnalités
nouvelles qui rentrent au gouvernement
je rappelle que il y a qu'une de ces
deux personnalités qui vient deslr
madame Vautrin a depuis longtemps quitté
leslr et de et de la même façon que ce
que vous dites marqué à droite sont des
gens qui sont déjà dans la Renaissance
depuis un moment monsieur darmana sa
carte à Renaissance Monsieur le Maire
aussi droite vienent de
droiteement ils viennent de droite il y
a aussi des gens dans cet hémicycle qui
viennent de gauche bon donc alors pour
répondre à votre question concrètement
sur Jean-Louis bourlange Jean-Louis
bourlange il pose une question avec sa
grande expérience c'est euh quel va être
le programme politique et c'est ça que
nous attendons effectivement avec
impatience parce que pour l'instant il y
a un seul ministre modem dans ces
ministères de plein exercice avec
beaucoup de ministres qui sont issus de
la droite Katia l'a dit le compte
n'y'est pas pour le modem pour l'instant
pour être représenté dans dans cet
exécutif moi j'aime pas parler de compte
parce que ça fait un peu apothicaaire et
et et c'est pas comme ça qu'on mais vous
souhaitez plutôt un rééquilibre souhaite
un rééquilibrage ma collègue Luquet
porte-parole du groupe avec moi on a
parlé de rééquilibrage audacieux
pour faire un écho à l'audace d'avoir un
premier ministre si jeune donc oui il
faut rééquilibrer il faut rééquilibrer
ne sera-ce que pour être en capacité à à
justement aller chercher des majorités
parfois avec les socio-démocrates et
avec les écologistes je suis sûr que sur
certains sujets on doit pouvoir y
arriver en tout cas moi c'est mon souit
alors à peine le gouvernement nommé
Amélie oua casterra la mil s'est
retrouvée en Pétré dans une polémique
sur la scolarisation de ses enfants dans
le privé est-ce que erouan balanan pour
vous une telle polémique avec une telle
polémique euh celle qui est la ministre
de l'école peut encore être légitime
alors deux choses déjà euh moi je je je
souhaite qu'on arrête cette chasse aux
sorcières à chaque fois sur les les
choix qui sont des choix personnels de
famille bon euh c'est
c'est dernière nouvelle l'école libre en
France privé n'est pas hors la loi donc
un ministre peut faire ce choix et
parfois on a vu que des euh pour fendeur
de ces systèmes mettaient aussi leurs
enfants dans des écoles privées donc
arrêtons la chasse aux sorcières c'est
le premier point après il y a un
deuxième point il y a une maladresse une
très grosse maladresse parl de mensonge
certains parlent de mensonges sur les
justifications pour lesquell elle a
retiré ses enfants du pu pas ça soit un
mensonge c'est euh justement par
sincérité et par envie de bien faire
d'avoir un peu réinventé ce qu'elle y
est ce qui était un souvenir elle l'a
dit elle s'en est excusé maintenant
est-ce que on va lui en vouloir et
est-ce que lui en vouloir fera avancer
la cause de l'éducation nationale qui
est pour moi un des axes principals de
ce de de cette séquence que nous devons
avoir donc faisons-lui confiance et moi
je le dis on lui fait confiance et je
dis aussi que lui faire un procès sans
arrêt c'est pas ça qui va faire avancer
la cause de l'éducation nationale mais
vous pensez pas qu'il ris d' avoir un
dialogue de Sour avec tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale dont
on sait qu'ils sont un peu remontés non
parce que son équipe va être complété je
pense qu'elle aura des secrétaires
d'État ou des ministres délégués sur sur
les sur quel sur les sujets et et et et
voilà il y a pas de raison que on avance
pas sur ces questions là sachant qu'en
plus on a un ministre prier un Premier
ministre qui est maintenant bien
imprégné de ces sujets et qui a une
volonté forte autour de l'éducation
nationale qui je le redis ça doit être
un des un des points saillants de cette
séquence et on devra retenir qu'on a
fait beaucoup pour l'éducation nationale
moi c'est un de mes souhait et il y a
une échance importante pour le Premier
ministre Gabriel Attal c'est le 30
janvier c'est la date de son discours de
PO que générale est-ce que ce discours
d'abord il sert vraiment à quelque chose
car on va le voir Emmanuel Macron a déjà
parlé a déjà dessiné la suite du
quinquena qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
ce discours de politique générale ah ben
non c'est pas la même chose le discours
du Président c'est un discours un peu
plus général et on n'est pas rentré j'ai
envie de dire dans le moteur on n pas
ouvert le capot et on n pas commencé à
faire la mécanique des décisions qu'on
doit prendre pour pour les temps qui
viennent donc moi j'attends
effectivement plusieurs choses déjà un
discours de politique général c'est
aussi une méthode quelle méthode Gabriel
Atal va mettre en place comment va-t-il
gouverner ça c'est quelque chose qui qu'
faut on a une attente là-dessus ensuite
il y a la déclinaison d'un certain
nombre de de de sujet sur des sujets
importants pour la vie des Français le
logement on en parlera peut-être la
santé évidemment l'éducation nationale
et puis un sujet important qui est qui
presque englobe tout qui est un peu la
mer des batailles c'est aussi la
transition écologique et notre position
dans le monde sur la méthode il veut
aller vite gouverner par circulaire par
décret vous craignez qu'il contourne le
Parlement non il pourra pas contourner
on est le Parlement le le Parlement dans
notre pays est difficilement
contournable parce que ça fait c'est un
c'est c'est le cœur battant de la
politique et de la démocratie donc c'est
il pourra pas contourner le gouvernement
et je sais qu'il n'a pas l'envie de le
Parlement pardon il a pasenvie de le
faire tout simplement parce que il est
parlementaire et il est parlementaire
dans l'âme en tout cas n'a pas demandé
de vote de confiance à l'issue de sa
déclaration de politique générale vous
le regrettez il manque de courage non il
manque pas de courage les les les règles
mathématiques de cette répartition sont
là la confi il ne l'aura pas ça ne sert
à rien de d'aller la la chercher c'est
comme ça on est en on est en majorité
relative donacte c'est pas le premier
ministre qui l'est et ça sera
certainement pas le premier minist pas
le dernier à être en majorité relative
dans ce pays en tout cas dans ce modèle
institutionnel alors on le disait le
président de la République a tenu cette
semaine une grande conférence de presse
pour dessiner la suite de son quinquena
beaucoup d'annonces sur l'école sur la
famille pour opérer ce qu'il appelle un
réarmement civique et démographique de
la France une vision qui n'a pas plu à
la gauche du Sénat Marion
dalpèche sans surprise au Sénat les
oppositions ne ressortent pas convaincu
par la prestation du chef de l'État jugé
loin des préoccupations des Français par
le sénateur communiste Yann brossa j'ai
vu un un long monologue pénible d'un
président de la République arrogant qui
ne répond en rien au problèmes des
Français en matière de pouvoir d'achat
de bas salaire de difficultés de la vie
quotidienne et donc je l'ai surtout
trouvé à côté de la plaque au regard de
de ces préoccupations là même son de
cloche pour le chef de fil des
socialistes au Sénat Patrick hanner
d'oir dans la conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron un exercice assumé
d'autosatisfaction le président Macron
hier m'a
rassuré notre pays va bien l'ascenseur
sociale fonctionne et nos services
publics ont les moyens de remplir leur
mission j'ai sans doute été distrait car
pour moi la réalité était tout autre
dans ma réalité l'école publique est
fragilisée par des professeur non
remplacé desabusés l'hôpital public
s'effondre dans ma réalité la France
compte désormais près de 5 million de
pauvres et la classe moyenne a de plus
en plus de mal à joindre les debouts
parmi la longue liste d'annonces faite
par le chef de l'État l'expérimentation
de l'uniforme à l'école un nouveau congé
de naissance un plan contre
l'infertilité ou encore le doublement de
l'enseignement civique des mesures
saluées par le sénateur François patria
soutient d'Emmanuel Macron je crois que
ce qu'a voulu dire le Président c'est
qu'il voulait faire des républicains et
faire des républicains c'est le rôle de
la famille c'est le rôle de l'école
c'est le rôle de l'entreprise c'est le
rôle de l'environnement général c'est le
rôle de la vie quotidienne je pense
qu'il était bon de de le rappeler non
pas de façon paternaliste comme je l'ai
entendu pas ici ou là mais de rappeler
que simplement dans son mode de vie dans
son respect vis-à-vis des autres on a
besoin aujourd'hui de redresser la barre
parce que ce n'est pas le cas voilà pour
ces réaction de sénateur à la conférence
de presse d'Emmanuel Macron le président
de la République qui a centré ses
annonces sur l'école la famille sur
l'ordre sur l'autorité pour je cite que
la France reste la France il a
d'ailleurs repris un slogan de campagne
d'erric Zemour est-ce que Erwan balanan
ce discours conservateur il correspond à
vos valeurs on est un peu loin des des
valeurs du MoDem quand même alors oui
enfin si si vous prenez comme ça et et à
votre lecture et à la lecture d'un
certain nombre de de d'observateurs mais
moi j'ai un peu approfondi et et j'ai
posé les questions à à certaines
personnes que que je connais qui sont
politisé sans sans être dans la
mécanique mais je suis désolé euh ils
m'ont dit mais en quoi euh la famille
c'est nécessairement une valeur de
droite en quoi l'école l'école c'est une
valeur de gauche euh quand on dit que il
va falloir euh réarmer l'école alors je
le dis moi j'aime pas cette j'aime pas
cette expression elle est guerrière je
préférerais qu'on dise réenchanter
l'école réenchanter le pays réenchanter
le le le le contrat républicain et et je
dirais plutôt le réenchantement que le
réarmement en quoi ce cette cette idée
làà serait une idée de droite je je
j'avoue que les brasment tombent en
réalité quand vous dites on va faire en
sorte de redonner du travail aux gens de
d'avancer sur la question salaire parce
que c'est des c'est des choses qui ont
été dites sur l'école dire que on va
donner la chance à tout le monde
d'acquérir les savoirs fondamentaux qui
permettent de réussir dans la vie en
quoi cela est de droite pas plus que de
gauche d'ailleurs al justement l'école
c'est un sujet que vous connaissez bien
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé une refondte
totale de l'instruction civique et
notamment l'expérimentation de la tenue
unique dans une centaine d'établissement
est-ce que pour vous c'est vraiment ce
type d'annonce ces mesures là qui
peuvent permettre de refonder l'école et
de résoudre les problème actuel de
l'école publique vous savez comment
fonctionne notre monde médiatique et
notre monde avec les réseaux sociaux il
y a besoin d'avoir des points d'accroche
et moi effectivement je ne pense pas que
c'est bien de faire l'expérimentation
c'est bien
d'essayer l'uniforme voilà pourquoi pas
testons mais je suis à peu près enfin
j'ai la conviction que c'est pas ça qui
va sauver l'école nécessairement ce qui
va sauver l'école c'est c'est aussi une
prise en compte de ce sujet par toute la
société de se dire l'école c'est
prioritaire et
réenchanter la la vie scolaire
réenchanter la la réussite parce que
c'est ça aussi l'école c'est de réussir
il y a des enfants qui sont issus de
milieu très populaire et qui par le
parcours de l'école qu'elle soit publ ou
privée réussissent des parcours
merveilleux et c'est ça qu'il faut
remontrer et on a plein d'exemples moi
j'ai des exemples dans les
collaborateurs que l'on croise parfois à
l'assemblée des gens qui ont des des
diplômes très élevés j'ai eu une
collaboratrice qui a commencé son
parcours par un beep dans une dans une
elle avait été mise dans elle était
scolarisée dans un endroit difficile et
on l'avait un peu assigné à résidence
elle s'est battu elle a réussi par
l'école à
devenir attaché parlementaire puis
membre d'un cabinet c'est des c'est des
exemples comme ça qu'il faut promouvoir
et c'est ça le réenchantement il me
semble qu'on doit qu'on doit qu'on doit
essayer de de promouvoir alors dans
cette conférence de presse le président
de la République qui a aussi confirmé la
baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards d'euros
pour les classes moyennes en 2025 contte
tenu de l'état de nos finances publiques
est-ce que c'est le moment d'annoncer
des baisses de recettes pour l'État ça
veut pas dire nécessairement des baisses
de recettes ou alors comment on les
finance c'est c'est ce c'est ce que nous
au modem on on on essayie de de pousser
depuis un moment c'est une répartition
plus juste et peut-être faire contribuer
des classes qui sont supérieures qui qui
aujourd'hui peuvent contribuer donc un
impôt sur les plus riches c'est ça qui
manque un impôt sur les plus riches pas
nécessairement j'aime pas ce terme sur
les plus riches en tout cas ceux qui ont
parce que dès qu'on s'amuse à définir la
richesse vous savez il y en a qui se
sont pris lesed les pieds dans le tapis
sur cette histoire donc non mais mieux
répartir trouver des des recettes
nouvelles nous on avait proposé des
choses autour des de la des taxation des
super qui n' jamais été retenu ça n'a
pas été retenu mais vous savez on est
généralement pugnas et on est
généralement déterminé on pourra avancer
effectivement je pense que les classes
moyennes
aujourd'hui méritent d'avoir leurs
impôts qui baissent ils sont toujours à
la limite entre ceux qui ont des aides
et ceux qui n'ont pas d'aide et ils se
retrouvent dans des situations parfois
difficiles alors qu'ils travaillent et
qu'ils ont des familles à nourrir et que
il y a parfois un sentiment d'injustice
qui qui qui n'est vous savez il y a pas
de grande démocratie sans grande sans un
sans sans des classes moyenne c'est
sociologiquement historiquement ça
n'existe pas donc on a besoin d'une
classe moyenne et surtout on a besoin
d'une classe moyenne qui a la conviction
que pour ses enfants si tout le monde
travaille s'il y a s'il y a une volonté
de réussir les la situation s'améliorera
dans dans la famille et et voilà c'est
tout simplement ça qu'il faut faire et
je crois que la répartition de la de
l'effort peut-être pe peut-êtreevu à la
marge certainement mais peut-êtreevu on
avait par exemple proposé plus de de
tranches d'impôt c'est quelque chose qui
permet de de lisser la la répartition
également le président a aussi été
interrogé sur la loi immigration il a
défendu la suppression de certaines
prestations sociales pour les étrangers
pendant un délai hein c'est une mesure
qui avait été ajoutée à ce texte par les
républicains je rappelle que Erwan
Balanant vous avez voté contre ce projet
de loi immigration est-ce que vous
espérez qu'il soit fortement censuré la
semaine prochaine par le Conseil
constitutionnel et si oui sur quel point
moi j'ai j'ai j'avais fait une liste d'à
peu près 30 dispositifs qui pourrai être
censurés donc on va voir fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup mais
le texte est très est très dense aussi
donc c'est pas non plus étonnant euh oui
moi j'espère qu'un certain nombre de
choses seront censurées euh c'est c'est
c'est un texte c'est pas le texte qu'on
voulait je crois que tout le monde est
conscient dans la majorité que c'était
pas le texte que
initial on avait un bon texte au départ
et c'est bien dommage qu'il y ait eu
cette séquence et ces coup politiques de
la gauche et de l'extrême droite qui qui
amène à cette à ce mauvais texte qui ne
sert à rien en l'état actuel des choses
donc il va être toqué et il y a
peut-être des dispositifs sur lequel on
va être obligé de revenir à un moment ou
un autre parce que par exemple l'article
4 Beast donc l'article de régularisation
qui sortit de la CMP nous on le dit il
est papier dans voilà dans les métiers
en S attention tel qu'il a été écrit il
est ni fait ni à faire donc c'est
peut-être des sujets sur lequel il
faudra revenir peut-être par voie
réglementaire d'ailleurs alors une
question sur un dernier point Emmanuel
Macron veut réarmer l'école un terme que
vous n'aimez pas vous préférez celui de
réenchantement il veut aussi un
réarmement démographique il dit et
inciter les Français à faire des enfants
à faire plus d'enfants est-ce que les
les enfants sont une arme est-ce que ça
vous choque ce terme de réarmement
démographique il a il a pris ce terme
parce que c'est un terme qu'il a repris
pour le réarmement civique pour le voilà
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas comment
vous comprenez
cette c'est pas pour faire des enfants
des une arme mais tout simplement notre
modèle social fonctionne sur un modèle
démographique et à partir du moment où
ce modèle démographique ne tient plus le
modèle social ne tient plus c'est c'est
c'est tout simple hein c'est de
l'économie niveau 1 donc et on a un
problème pour les retraites et on on a
un problème pour les retraites mais pas
que pour les retraites pour le
financement de notre modèle social dans
son ensemble donc oui voilà pendant très
longtemps on a eu un taux de fertilité
qui permettait le renouvellement
aujourd'hui on est comme beaucoup de
pays en Europe sans ce taux de
renouvellement il va falloir peut-être
avoir des politiques familiales mais
avoir des politiques familiales c'est
pas retomber dans les vieilles
politiques familiales un peu par terre
l'un list d'un autre temps aider les
femmes à avoir des enfants c'est aider
les couples à avoir des enfants et
surtout aider les femmes tout au long de
leur carrière pour que elles ne soient
pas comment dire les grandes perdantes
de cette politique nataliste et
là-dessus moi je serais très vigilant
vous savez le la différence de
patrimoine créé par une femme et un
homme sur l'ensemble d'une carrière la
moyenne c'est 500000 € 500000
une très belle maison dans nos provinces
et en Bretagne donc c'est un vrai sujet
alors on va revenir à l'Assemblée
nationale Erwan bananon puisque le
projet de loi constitutionnel destiné à
graver l'IVG dans la Constitution a été
adopté en commission des lois le texte
sera examiné le 24 janvier en séance
publique il reviendra au Sénat en
février avant d'être soumis
éventuellement au congrès de députés et
sénateurs c'est ce que souhaite Emmanuel
Macron Éric Dupont moréti qui porte le
texte est très optimiste écoutez on a un
grand texte de liberté c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on peut tous ensemble euh
préparer porter voter en ce qui vous
concerne un texte de liberté alors soit
on choisit de chipoter mais c'est pas ce
que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui soit euh on
consacre ce texte on va l'inscrire dans
la dans la Constitution dans notre
Constitution et ce sera oui le Conseil
d'État a cru utile de le rappeler la
première fois qu'un pays inscrit dans sa
constitution cette
liberté si j'étais familier je vous
dirais ça de la gueule si je le suis
moins je peux vous dire ça quand même
beaucoup d'allure eran Balanant vous
êtes optimiste selon vous le Parlement
va adopter cette inscription de l'IVG
dans la Constitution ah ben je l'espère
oui j'espère qu'on va avoir cette cette
avancée qui est une avancée qui est ce
que j'ai expliqué moi en commission
c'est une sorte défit cliquet
c'est-à-dire que on dit notre pays dit
on ne reviendra jamais en arrière sur ce
sujet on l'inscrit dans la plus dans le
plus haut des textes dans notre
Constitution mais personne ne veut
revenir en arrière sur l'IVG personne ne
ve j'ai envie de vous dire mon œil mon
œil quand on aentendu les débats quand
on voit certains amendements portés par
certaines familles politiques en France
et je pense au LR et au rassemblement
national mon œil il y a des gens qui
veulent revenir en arrière il y a des
gens qui quand ils seront au pouvoir
reviendront peut-être en arrire de
certains députés LR ça pourrait oui
parfaitement don pas seulement du
rassemblement national pas seulement du
rassemblement national donc mettons cet
effet de cliquet le texte tel qu'il a
été écrit qui est le le fruit d'un d'un
consensus entre l'écriture qui était
d'ailleurs avec un peu de fierté je le
dis mon écriture à l'Assemblée nationale
le 22 novembre 2022 lors du text adopté
voilà et ensuite le Sénat qui a eu une
vision un petit peu différente et il y a
un consensus qui s'est fait et
maintenant il faut aller jusqu'au bout
et il faut qu'on ait les débats parce
que ça sera des beaux débats et des
débats qui marqueront aussi l'histoire
politique de notre pays mais justement
vous vous étiez impliqué dans le la
rédaction d'un amendement commun qui
avait permis de de trouver un accord
transpartisan sur le texte initial
présenté par Mathilde Panau de la France
insoumise est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
formulation telle qu'elle est retenue
vous convient parce que vous vous
souhaitiez non pas reconnaître une
liberté mais reconnaître inscrire dans
la Constitution le droit femmes à
recourir à moi je suis satisfait parce
Queen réalité après discussion avec un
certain nombre de constitutionnalistes
euh les deux sont ont la même portée
effective et euh juridique donc si c'est
que un problème sémantique et de de
vocabulaire on va pas on va pas se se
faire des nœuds au cerveau pour ça par
contre en plus ce qui est intéressant
c'est que l'écriture telle qu'elle a été
faite sur ce travail de consensus elle
est encore un peu mieux parce que moi
j'avais pas pensé effectivement à
l'article 34 et c'était dommage parce
que l'article 34 de la Constitution il
va être un nouvel alinéa de l'article 34
de la Constitution et ça lui donne
encore plus de force que là où on
l'avait mis avec un article 66-2 qui
était un peu maladroitement placé juste
après la peine de mort enfin voilà on a
quelque chose qui comme l'a dit 34 c'est
la loi c'est le cœur de la loi oui c'est
la loi c'est la loi et et pour tous ceux
qui peut-être découvrent le droit
constitutionnel que ça soit l'article 1
ou le dernier article de notre
Constitution ils ont toutes tous la même
portée et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup balanan d'avoir été le premier
invité de l'année de Parlement Hebdo
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission et à la semaine prochaine ciao
ciao
[Musique]